hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 chinese action movie called a man
called hero
the movie begins with a group of ninjas
called five element ninjas who attack
shifu jin al's place
each one of them masters one of the
elements of water soil fire metal and
wood
jinao's two disciples huwa yingxiong
also called hero and a masked ghost
servant attempt to defend the place the
ninjas aim to steal the scroll of
chinese pride a highly skilled kung fu
technique
hiro is almost killed by one of the
ninjas but another ninja mew forbids her
reminding her that they are only
stealing the scroll not killing people
they succeed in stealing the scroll only
for woody their master to discover that
it does not contain the kung fu
technique
jin au casually eating chicken informs
his disciples that the technique is not
contained in the scrolls but can only be
passed down by him to someone he deems
worthy
after the attack hiro is walking in the
open market with his wife jay you
they encounter an old blind beggar who
sings about hiro's destiny he tells them
that he is destined to be an unlucky
star bringing bad fortune to his teacher
and families
hero's loyal servant shang dislikes the
beggar and drives him away
hiro tries not to think too much of the
song
suddenly ghost's servant comes to him
informing him about another attack at
jin al's place
they quickly helped jin au who receives
an unwelcome guest woody himself
woody is disappointed as their former
shifu would not grant the chinese pride
to him because he is japanese
he summons a giant to attack janelle but
being far more skillful than him jin now
calmly defends himself with ease badly
hurt woody retreats
however it is discovered that jin au has
also been seriously hurt knowing he does
not have much time he intends on passing
the chinese pride to hero
while passing the knowledge he projects
hiro out of his physical body allowing
him to read the chinese pride technique
projected around him in the spiritual
realm
however after that hiro sees flashbacks
of his past as well as the foretelling
of his grim future
after that jin now dies
sometime later hiro is informed that his
parents residence has been attacked
he learns that the five element ninjas
have killed his parents to draw him out
so they can obtain the chinese pride
facing the attack hero barely makes it
until he is saved by ghost servant
he suggests hiro lay low in thailand and
take his time to practice the chinese
pride until he can master it and use it
against the five elements
shang arranges the departure for hiro
and his pregnant wife to thailand
tomorrow meanwhile woody is still deeply
insulted after being defeated by jinao
and told that he was not worthy to
become a samurai
knowing from the ninjas that hiro
escaped his wrath takes control of him
accidentally killing his son and wife he
instructs them to find hiro before he
can master the chinese pride or hero
will be too powerful for all of them to
defeat
arriving in thailand hiro helps defend a
chinese worker who is beaten by an
american man
the boss of the american acknowledges
his kung fu skills and offers him a job
guarding a rock quarry
looking around the quarry hiro learns
that the chinese workers there are
treated unfairly thus he uses his kung
fu and mystic skills to get rid of the
americans when his strength wears off he
is saved by a group of bandits which
turn out to be subordinates of yuan wu a
powerful chinese in thailand and also a
friend of the ghost servant
wu offers hiro and his family to live in
his building and takes good care of him
the chinese workers now officially label
him a hero and praise him he writes
about his condition to ghost servant as
well as attaching a family photo of him
and his wife
while reading the letter ghost's servant
is distracted by a sound leaving it on
the table
one of the five element ninjas kim who
has been secretly stalking him reads the
letter and deciphers hero's location
he has already fled when ghost servant
comes back
the five element ninjas arrive at yuan
wu's building where hiro and his wife
live
a battle ensues between hiro and the
ninjas
hiro seems to have upgraded his skills
as he causes a lot of trouble for the
ninjas
ghost servant arrives at the battle
scene just in time to give back up kim
is almost killed but he uses mu's body
to shield himself from hero's attacks
thus he escapes the badly hurt mew is
left behind
hiro remembering that mew saved his life
earlier by deciding not to kill him
decides to return the favor and takes
her to wu's building
mew says she needs to get back to which
hiro does not forbid but she is
surprised to see hiro entering his room
later while she is packing her things
and initiating an affair with her
however in the morning mew gets
heartbroken as she sees hero assisting
his wife
enraged with envy she goes back to the
ninjas intending to attack hiro as
revenge
kim assures her that they will
successfully kill hiro this time
one of the ninjas initiates a fire in
the storage rooms of wu's building
making everyone evacuate at the same
time ju feels she will give labor to her
children
hiro and chung wait impatiently outside
of her room but are forced to help the
people evacuate
kim attacks you on woo and takes his
appearance to full hero
ju gives birth to a set of twins a boy
and a girl the latter bearing a
birthmark on her lower chin kim
disguised as yuan wu comes to ju's room
to congratulate the family on the twins
then takes one of them and instructs
hiro to evacuate his wife as well
however ju dies shortly after sending
hiro into deep grief
he is much more shocked to learn that
one of his children has been taken by
yuan wu's doppelganger the surviving
five elements ninjas including mew
regroup after the attack
mew sees kim holding one of hero's
babies then she realizes his intention
to blackmail hiro using this child
furthermore she also realizes that the
one having an affair with her was not
the real hero but kim in disguise so she
will become motivated to hate an attack
hero
she attempts to take the child from kim
and paralyzes his limb but fails
meanwhile woody asked to be met with
hiro
at ju's funeral hiro shang and ghost
servant are mourning
hiro acknowledges his destiny to be the
unlucky star as his wife is now gone and
one of his children is probably gone as
well
he instructs shang to take good care of
his son while he isolates himself to
learn the chinese pride for 20 years
he promises to meet his son on the night
of the autumn festival 20 years later
suddenly moody arrives and hiros still
cannot match his powers ghost servant
helps him escape
later hiro works hard every day to learn
the chinese pride accompanied by ghost
servant
as he grows up jiayang's iong hero's son
behaves just like his father always
standing up when chinese people are
treated poorly
he also learns kung fu
sheng regularly writes letters to inform
jiayang zion's condition to his father
finally the night of the autumn festival
arrives and jiang zion is really excited
to meet his father
however ghost servant informs him that
hiro may not arrive as he still has some
matters to be taken care of
the five elements now rebranded as the
black dragon initiate a riot to draw
jayang zyong woo shung and ghost servant
out so hero will come to save them the
ninjas only consist of kim the water
ninja and another mysterious girl as all
other members have been defeated in
previous encounters with hiro
when jiang xiong woo shang and ghost
servant are cornered from all sides hiro
finally appears using his powers to
deflect bullets aimed at his son and
companions
he defeats the water ninja and kim
easily using his kung fu skills who sees
the unconscious ninja girl and almost
kills him but hiro halts him and
examines the birthmark on the girl's
lower chin
he discovers that she is her long-lost
daughter chong tian
hiro takes her to be treated in wu's
building then distances himself again
from his family knowing that woody will
arrive for their ultimate battle
after regaining consciousness chong tian
still antagonizes her helpers and
attempts to go back to woody but ghost
servant explains the truth
at first she does not believe that she
is the daughter of the famous chinese
hero as kim told her that she has been
an orphan since birth
however coming back to woody he confirms
the story and admits that he only uses
her as bait to draw hiro out then
restrains her woody exclaims in front of
wu's building that he is hero's daughter
so hiro better come out and battle him
yuan wu and his men including jiang
xiong try to fight him but to no avail
now moody has both of hiro's children
but just as he is about to kill them mew
shows up and attempts to restrain him
she says that as long as she is alive
woody cannot lay his fingers on hiro's
children
mew's powers are enough to distract
woody for some time but she eventually
cannot match him and is defeated during
her last breaths hiro comes to comfort
her
finally ready to face woody hiro
prepares himself while woody uses a
three-headed snake giant to fight for
him
hiro defeats the creature easily
next they engage in a sword fight but
hiro's wooden sword is no match for
wudai's katana with his sword broken and
himself badly hurt hiro is almost
hopeless as woody summons another giant
to finish him but then his shifu jinao
appears telling him that anything can be
fought with the power of love hiro then
acknowledges the love and support he has
received then projects an energy sword
from his fingers
that sword hurts woody badly until he
admits defeat
hiro tells him that as long as he is
full of hatred he cannot fully master
the chinese pride after the battle hero
is determined to venture on his own
again defending the chinese people from
unjust treatment although his children
beg for him to stay he already made up
his mind then leaves
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching